the Greens have a busy Congress ahead of  them delegates have put forward some  2,600 amendments to the party's election  platform the focus is on tax policy the  Greens want to raise the top rate of tax  but disagree on whether to introduce an  additional wealth tax your Muslim should  nap we need to pay down the debt a  wealth tax on personal assets can help  and it affects only 1% of the population  per couple ahead of September's federal  elections green leaders are pushing the  party's alliance with the main  opposition Social Democrats and  rejecting talk of a possible coalition  with the conservative CDU which only if  the greens are strong will there be a  majority beyond the center right and  only if the greens are strong can there  be an SPD green coalition in government  Oh Glenn and coy leads on the guillen in  a move underscoring the two parties ties  SPD lead at Sigma Gabrielle is due to be  a guest speaker at the Greens Congress